não fosse em goianá
e que eu não quero passar isso cara
as várias faro ficando os feitos que me
levam com a cara dos inimigos se lascar
eu tive que jogar
[Música]
e pra mim tá passar
só me fazem morrer pra eu não entendi
que sei é que eu não posso parar
olhe bem
os meus olhos e fica pra mim o meu é que
pode você vai quebrar
esse cano parece
tem eu já tentei passado é possível
aceitar ou jogar
talvez vocês não entendam essa coisa de
fazer um
acreditar
na próxima
o bater o recorde
vou jogar essa [__] até a morte
até um acabar
o hotel
acaba
ah
até um dia acaba
mas tal bem
vocês não entendam essa coisa de fazer
um
a acreditar
minha próxima
i go bateu o recorde por jogar essa
[__] até a morte
até 11 de acabar
até um honda acaba
até 1
[Música]
[Aplausos]
até 1
acaba
do capiroto
[Música]